♪ ♪ ♪
- Ça faisait très longtemps
que Marie attendait pour
apporter sa robe.
♪ ♪ ♪
Enfin, elle peut se marier
avec François, son amoureux
des 20 dernières années.
MARIE ROBERT
- Ça fait depuis deux ans que
je travaille fort là-dessus.
Moi, je voulais avoir de
quoi pour dire aux invités
qu'ils étaient importants
dans nos coeurs, qu'ils étaient
les bienvenus.
FRANÇOIS CLAING
- Tout est prêt. Tout est là.
Tout est fait à la main.
- Le couple avait prévu se
marier en 2020, puis en 2021,
et finalement, en
- On avait mis notre date
initiale dessus, qui était
le 25 juillet 2020. On a
décidé de laisser ça comme ça.
(claps)
- Et l'événement est encore plus
significatif qu'il y a deux ans.
- L'année qu'on était supposés
se marier, François a été
déclaré qu'il avait un cancer.
Ça fait qu'il a été opéré, il
a eu des traitements de chimio.
Il a eu une autre opération.
- Mais là on est correct,
on a passé au travers.
- On a passé au travers.
- Au fil du temps, des proches
sont décédés. D'autres se sont
éloignéslier la COVID,
qui fait toujours des siennes.
Si bien que les invités sont
passés de 126 à 90. Ce qui n'a
pas empêché le budget, lui,
de bondir de 50 %, à 30 000 $.
- Ici, j'ai été chanceuse.
J'ai eu une petite augmentation,
mais minime à comparer... c'est
vraiment acceptable. La musique
aussi, mais j'ai "dealé" aussi
parce qu'il voulait me monter.
La coiffeuse, c'est pareil,
t'sais, ça a monté comme
de 150 $ de plus.
Mais c'est normal.- J'aime beau.
- La saison est hyper occupée
pour toute l'industrie du
mariage, selon cette
atrice.
MÉLANIE AUBIN, propriétaire,
Foudamour
- Ça roule un petit peu carré.
Ça roule bien, mais
effectiveffectiveffectiveffectip
de pénurie de main-d'oeuvre dans
plusieurs salles. Non seulement
au niveau des salles, mais
des traiteurs, fleuristes.
- La plupart des fournisseurs
ont honoré les contrats reportés
avec des hausses de prix
limitées.
frent la possibilité
aux gens de changer d'idée ou
de prendre quelque chose de
moins dispendieux.
- Les mariages planifiés plusrés
fortement l'inflation.
-  C'est sûr et certain qu'il
y a un bon 20 à 25 % de plus
cher dans les factures, oui.
- Par rapport à l'an dernier?
- Oui.
- Elle s'attend à une autre
augmentation d'au moins 25 %
pour les mariages de l'an
prochain.
- Probablement quevont
décider peut-être de réduire
aussi. Parce que c'est sûr
que la seule façon de réduire
un budget de mariage, c'est
de réduire le nombre d'invités.
Donc, les gens qui me disent
qu'ils veulent inviter
200 personnes, puis qui ont
un budget de 20 000 $, c'est sûr
que c'est difficile à faire.
- Le Centre des congrès
de Saint-Hyacinthe accueille
une vingtaine de mariages
cette année, soit le double
de la normale.
AUDREY VINCENT, coordonnatrice,
Centre des congrès, St-Hyacinthe
- On maintient toutes
les tarifications
prises. Par la suite, pour ce
qui est des années prochaines,
c'est sûr qu'on a des
augmentations à prévoir.
Facilement un 15-2
d'augmentation.
- Il y a déjà une demi-douzaine
de réservations pour l'an
prochain et plusieurs demandes
pour 202
- C'est sûr qu'ils sont toujours
mieux de se prendre plus tôt que
tard. Parce que définitivement,
si ce n'est pas la tarification
qui va changer, c'est
la disponibilité des salles
qu'on n'aura plus.
JEAN-MARC ALAZET, copropriétaire
Maison d'Evelyne
- Nous, on bloque les prix à peu
près six mois avant le mariage.
À ce moment-là, on garantit
le prix era. Mais là,
on n'a aucune idée de ce qui va
se passer, absolument aucune.
On est complet pour 2022,
puis on finit 2023.
♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪
- Marie et François, eux,
ont arrêté de planifier et ils
réalisent enfin leur rêve.
- On voit ça festif, puis
plein d'amour entre nousdeux, m,
nos enfants, nos petits-enfants,
nos frères et soeurs. Ça,
c'est important pour nous, ça.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Et les mariés peuvent dire....
Ici Marie-Claude Morin,
Radio-Canada, Saint-Jude.